Marty McFly's hoverboard in the nineteen
eighty nine film back to the future two
had kids captivated the world over
hoverboard now the dream is a reality
well sort of developed by us startup
arks packs the Hendo hoverboard uses
technology called magnetic field
architecture magnets inside the board
create a field that allows it to hover
about an inch above non-magnetic
surfaces like this copper halfpipe the
writer needs to lean in a particular
direction to convince the board to
follow and this kind of tech is used in
other places maglev trains use a similar
system but on a much much larger scale
the high-speed trains float above the
tracks to hit up to 300 miles per hour
this is just a prototype arcs packs
hopes a Kickstarter campaign will help
generate bigger ideas for the technology
and the money to make them a reality the
designer hopes these ideas will one day
be used at preventing buildings from
being damaged by earthquakes a developer
kit containing just an engine can be
yours for 299 dollars a fully working
bored that'll set you back 10,000
millions of Marty fans will be hoping
the developers get this idea off the
ground